megan wants to know what number am i
thinking of
um no megan wants to know i recently
read that mit folks found bruises in the
cosmic background radiation indicating
regions where our universe may have hit
other universes how can our universe
expand forever if there are other
universes outside it yeah so you can
expand forever in
if you're in a higher dimension if
you're embedded in a higher dimension
you can expand without anybody ever
bumping into anybody for example
consider a rubber sheet and you take a
rubber sheet and stretch it you can make
it as big as you want you could take
another rubber sheet put it one inch
below that one and stretch that as big
as you want two rubber sheet universes
stretching forever never colliding never
touching one but but if it was at a
slight angle it would hit each i think
what she's saying well what i'm saying
is you yes if it was flat it would hit
but you could even in an even higher
bounds in an even higher dimension it's
just how many dimensions you embed it in
a two-dimensional rubber sheet in three
dimensions yeah if you tip it it'll
embed it in four dimensions
you can do this forever yes so that's a
b
if you're near another universe
gravitational effects
permeate the boundaries of your universe
and can touch another universe
so in principle we could feel the
effects of other universes embedded in
this higher dimensional space that could
be simply
the the the
the the meta fabric of the multiverse
right so you're saying ghosts are real
and they're people in another universe
that happen to live inside your house in
a rubber sheet
except i never understood why the ghosts
that people see are not naked because it
means their clothing is ghost as well
yeah yeah why are they wearing clothing
at all i think because they might be
make-believe
okay that's just one theory i have outer
skin layer is dead and your hair is dead
i mean if you're a living ghost you're
why the why do they have they have a
pepperdasher and it's all really little
it's scary little girls the whole thing
doesn't really come
the together